glasgow klimakonferenz im november 2000
21 die welt hat einen auftrag den
temperaturanstieg auf der erde so
schnell wie möglich in den griff zu
bekommen
wer das schaffen will und wie das
erfahrt ihr in diesem video wir schauen
auf die big player in sachen co2 das
pariser klimaabkommen den
emissionshandel und werfen einen blick
in die zukunft
die uhr tickt
die big player in sachen co2 unser
enormer co2 ausstoß ist maßgeblich für
die erderwärmung verantwortlich
am ende dieses videos werden es weltweit
circa 450.000 tonnen co2 mehr sein das
meiste co2 verursacht derzeit china fast
ein drittel aller jährlichen emissionen
gefolgt von den usa und an dritter
stelle europa zusammen produzieren diese
drei hauptverursacher mehr als die
hälfte aller emissionen weltweit
in china wird ein großes umlenken noch
länger dauern die aufholjagd zur
industrie nation ist in vielen regionen
noch in vollem gange so plant china erst
ab 2030 die co2 emissionen zu reduzieren
derzeit wird die hälfte der weltweit
geförderten kohle in china verbrannt und
neben dem bestehenden kohlekraftwerken
sind dort über 200 weitere geplant oder
im bau
immerhin im ausland will das land nun
keine weiteren kohlekraftwerke mehr
bauen sondern die entwicklung
klimafreundlicher technologien
unterstützen
im jahr 2060 will china dann
klimaneutral sein also nicht mehr co2
ausstoßen als in der natur gebunden
werden kann
die usa wollen für den klimaschutz 400
milliarden us dollar in den nächsten
zehn jahren in erneuerbare energien und
nachhaltige projekte investieren ende
september hat us präsident joe biden
verkündet dass im jahr 2030 die hälfte
aller neuwagen in den usa elektroautos
seien so
klimaneutral wollen sie bis 2050 werden
mit dem green deal der eu sollen die
klima- und umweltschutzmaßnahmen der eu
staaten noch mal verstärkt werden dabei
soll der co2 ausstoß bis 2030 um mehr
als die hälfte im vergleich zu 1990
reduziert werden das reicht aber nicht
aus kritisieren
umweltschutzorganisationen
die emissionen müssten stärker gesenkt
werden bis 2050 soll auch die eu
klimaneutral sein
das pariser klimaabkommen
2015 haben fast alle staaten der welt in
paris einen vertrag zum schutz des
klimas beschlossen das ziel den
temperaturanstieg auf der erde im
durchschnitt auf deutlich unter zwei
grad im vergleich zur vorindustriellen
zeit zu begrenzen möglichst bei 15 grad
celsius im durchschnitt sind die
temperaturen jetzt schon um über ein
grad gestiegen an vielen orten liegt der
anstieg sogar deutlich darüber zum
beispiel in der nordpolarregion
dort hat sich die eisdecke durch die
milderen winter um fast die hälfte
reduziert das pariser abkommen sieht vor
die hauptverursacher in die
verantwortung zu nehmen mit geld
jährlich sind 100 milliarden us dollar
bis 2025 angepeilt die allerdings längst
nicht beisammen sind und auch mit
konkreter hilfe dort wo der klimawandel
schon spürbar ist die aktuelle prognose
des weltklimarates bezieht sich auf
unterschiedlich starke anstrengungen der
vertragsstaaten und berechnet danach die
temperatur entwicklungen es wird
deutlich mit den aktuellen plänen
treibhausgase einzusparen ist das ziel
nicht erreichbar
deshalb gibt das pariser klimaabkommen
auch vor die länder sollen regelmäßig
nach justieren ihre pläne immer weiter
verbessern und dann strikt einhalten
genau das soll jetzt in glasgow
passieren
der emissionshandel ein hebel mit dem
die staatengemeinschaft den co2 ausstoß
reduzieren will ist der handel mit
emissionspapieren und das funktioniert
so eine zentrale behörde verkauft eine
begrenzte anzahl von co2
emissionszertifikaten je nachdem wie
viele zertifikate ein unternehmen
erwirbt darf es die entsprechende menge
co2 ausstoßen und zahlt den preis dafür
ein vorreiter ist die eu die bereits
2005 ihr emissionshandelssystem für
industriestrom wirtschaft und
mittlerweile auch flugverkehr eingeführt
hat die bilanz ist bisher mittelmäßig
immerhin der emissionsausstoß der
sektoren ist seit 2005 von über zwei
milliarden tonnen auf unter 1 5
milliarden tonnen jährlich gesunken die
usa haben bisher nur in einzelnen
bundesstaaten
emissionshandelssysteme china hat
kürzlich ein nationales programm
eingeführt seit diesem jahr verpflichtet
es von 2.200 chinesische unternehmen die
etwa 40 prozent der chinesischen
emissionen verursachen doch
emissionshandel ist umstritten die einen
preisen ihn als die kosteneffizienteste
klima lösung an andere kritisieren dass
das system nicht richtig greife solange
der preis pro tonne zu gering ist hat
das system nämlich kaum einen effekt
lange zeit kostete die tonne in der eu
nur etwa fünf euro ende september 2021
ist der preis auf über 60 euro gestiegen
so kann tatsächlich ein umlenken erwirkt
werden doch dafür müssen dann auch
ausreichend klimafreundliche
technologien zur verfügung stehen
ausblick im sommer 2021 hat der
klimawandel auch in der westlichen welt
seine unterschiedlichen facetten durch
extreme wetterereignisse deutlich
gezeigt trotzdem vor allem
industrieländer können zurzeit mit den
folgen des klimawandels noch ganz gut
umgehen der weltrisikobericht zeigt
härter trifft es viele länder des
globalen südens die schon lange mit
extrem wettern kämpfen und weniger geld
für schutz und wiederaufbau haben am
ende geht es tatsächlich schon um ein
halbes grad wenn es gelingt den
temperaturanstieg auf 1 5 grad zu
begrenzen werden die folgen deutlich
überschaubarer sein als bei zwei grad
und mehr bei zwei grad wird ein anstieg
des meeresspiegels von 50 zentimetern
bis zum ende des jahrhunderts berechnet
eine starke bedrohung für alle
küstengebiete
extremwetterereignisse werden deutlich
häufiger und heftiger auftreten außerdem
wird dieser anstieg auf stärkere
auswirkungen auf die artenvielfalt der
pflanzen und tierwelt haben einhalten
können wir das 15 grad ziel nur noch
wenn wir auf möglichst viele strategien
gleichzeitig setzen emissionen
reduzieren und natürliche co2 speicher
bewahren industrie und verkehr
nachhaltig machen und vor allem müssen
wir unsere energie systeme weltweit
drastisch umbauen am besten sofort
[Musik]